[російською] Давайте, давайте, народ! [свист]
Швидше!
[російською] Ну човен мені скинути тренерський, поїхали!
[російською] Дружненько взялися!
[російською] Дружненько взялися, раз-два, поїхали!
[російською] На смужечку, на смужечку!
[російською] Направляючі, на смужечку!
[російською] Поїхали!
[російською] Потягнули корму.
[російською] Ніс не тягніть, корму тягніть, альо!
[російською] Захочеш поправитись — не поправишся!
[російською] Дитяча спортивна школа № 2.
[російською] Тут займаються діти
греблею на байдарках і каное.
[російською] І також відділення вітрильного спорту.
[російською] Зараз подивимося, чим будемо займатися.
[російською] Загальна фізична підготовка, підтягування,
відтискання і виправні роботи.
[російською] Я — заміж за яхтсмена вийшла. От і все!
[російською] Довелося займатися.
[російською] У нас дуже велика крейсерська яхта є,
але вона зараз на приколі стоїть.
[російською] Довелося вчитися.
[російською] Це цікаво, вчитися ніколи не пізно.
[російською] Тут вся територія була встелена вітрилами.
[російською] У будь-якому місці,
куди би ви не ткнулися — були яхт-клубики.
[російською] Були діти,
що займались вітрильним спортом.
[російською] Тобто все Дніпро таке було.
[російською] Раніше навіть великі судна, навіть Ракети,
і то поступалися дорогою яхтсменам.
[російською] В 1990-х роках все повністю зникло.
[російською] Але чоловік продовжував
займатися дітьми без зарплати, без нічого.
[російською] Ми працювали на інших роботах,
а дітьми займались.
[російською] Десять років пробивали
відділення вітрильного спорту.
[російською] Хоча б аби зарплату тренери отримували.
[російською] От з 2005 року існує
відроджене відділення вітрильного спорту.
[російською] Трудимося. Вийшла така сімейна справа.
[російською] Чоловіки-тренери не захотіли
від початку йти на таку маленьку зарплату.
[російською] Ще коли набирали,
а потім і не виявилось тренерів.
[російською] У нас кажуть серед тренерів України,
[російською] що тренер з вітрильного спорту —
як дресирований жираф.
[російською] Ви коли-небудь
бачили дресированих жирафів? Ні!
[російською] Так ось тренерів з вітрильного спорту
можна на пальцях перелічити.
[російською] Щоби любити дітей,
займатись цим, оце ремонтувати.
[російською] Їздити постійно — має бути душа.
[російською] Зараз прогріється двигун.
[російською] Чим хороший вітрильний спорт? Природа, вода!
[російською] Все що хочеш.
[російською] У нас після походів батьки телефонують
і кажуть, особливо батьки хлопчиків:
[російською] «Ой, Ларисо Василівно, дякуємо вам,
ви навчили дітей чистити картоплю».
[російською] Виявляється, діти не знали,
що перед тим, як кидати в суп — картоплю треба чистити.
[російською] Тут на стелажі в нас вітрила.
[російською] Рятувальні жилети.
[російською] У нас правило номер один —
без рятувального жилету ніхто на воду не виходить
[російською] Забув жилет — відтиснувся 100 разів
[російською] Ну чи 20.
Як я придумаю — то справа така.
[російською] І так само тренери наші так роблять.
[російською] Ех, діти!
[російською] Оце дві сестрички, а взагалі їх три.
[російською] Одна займається каное на іншій базі.
[російською] Ця займається вітрильним спортом.
[російською] Ну і будемо цю готувати ще.
– [російською] А ця футболом.
– [російською] Ця футболом?
– [російською] Так, в садочку вона займається.
– [російською] Ну все, розподілили дітей.
[російською] Оце старі-старі човники.
[російською] Оцю за цей рік я так розумію,
що вже доб'ють, бо вона вже не буде підлягати ремонту.
[російською] Оці ще більш-менш.
[російською] Це 1970-х - 1980-х років човни.
[російською] Ми коли іншим тренерам України кажемо,
[російською] що ми ходимо в ліс по гриби на яхті.
[російською] У всіх ця фраза викликає сильне здивування.
[російською] Це як можна в ліс ходити на яхті по гриби?
[російською] А ми кожну осінь,
в нас є одне місце в Голопристанському районі.
[російською] Там є озеро велике,
яхта стає прямо в берег.
[російською] Втикаємося носом
і пішли в ліс збирати гриби.
[російською] Ввечері багаття.
[російською] Там не стільки тих грибів,
але набісяться діти, накричаться.
[російською] Колись мама одна зі мною поїхала,
каже: «Боже, як ви терпите ці крики»
[російською] Я кажу: «А де дітям кричати?
На вулиці не можна, в школі не можна.
[російською] Та нехай горланять, тут ліс!»
[російською] Як воно вийде далі?
Хотілось би більше усього.
[російською] Це красиво, це здорово.
[російською] Діти, що займаються вітрильним спортом.
[російською] Вони розбираються і у фізиці,
і в математиці, і в геометрії.
[російською] Все що завгодно.
[російською] У нас немає жодного спортсмена,
який би не поступив у вищий навчальний заклад.
[російською] У нас всі поступили ті діти, що займалися.
[російською] І майстрів спорту скільки було в нас.
[російською] І кандидатів у майстри спорту.
[російською] На Олімпійські Ігри перші їздили
херсонські діти — Ларичева Софія та Бабич Павло.
[російською] В Сінгапур у 2010 році.
[російською] Як кажуть, якби виграв мільйон,
щоб ти з ним зробив?
[російською] Роздам борги.
А інші? А інші почекають.
[російською] Так от краще б я вклала сюди гроші
і зробила би шикарний центр підготовки
[російською] гребних видів спорту і вітрильного спорту.
[російською] Територія — чудова, акваторія — також.